hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sail ist es
heute gibt es ein richtig leckeres
herzhaftes rezept und zwar werden wir
druck machen und zwar ist es eine
russische spezialität dass ich kurz
gegart ist im prinzip vergleichbar mit
unseren türkischen türk etwas was wir
schon mal gemacht haben oder
also man nimmt es einem ritter findet es
wird dann kurz angebraten und dann nach
belieben auch verfeinert hier ist die
besonderheit dass es sauer abgeschmeckt
wird als mit sauer rahmen manchmal auch
mit essig zitronensaft und auch sauren
gurken super lecker wir haben heute
sogar noch pilze mit dabei und zwar
shopping jungs steinpilze und ausland
pilze jetzt denkt ihr wahrscheinlich
menschen sind aber ganz schön viele
zutaten und auch teilweise ja nicht ganz
so günstiger zu haben ist ein bisschen
untertrieben ist ein tolle zu teuer aber
es ist ja auch nicht kein gericht wohl
jetzt gibt's mittagsmagazin haut aber
sicher etwas festliches aber das kann
man echt mal zu einem besonderen anlass
machen und wir haben jetzt rinderfilet
verwendet das ist wirklich ein teures
fleisch steckt muss man dazu sagen
aber ihr könnt zum beispiel auch rinder
nacken nehmen oder schmorbraten bei spuk
nehmen und das ganz einfach ein bisschen
länger schmoren bei niedriger stufe und
dann wird es auch superzahl
so also wenn man kurz gebratenes machen
möchte sollte man schon ein zartes filet
nehmen weil es dann eben einfach
ziemlich fad wird und nicht sehen also
sich kein schwäbischer schrittweise ein
schwäbisches ich habe alle zutaten in
der schmuckabteilung geholt japan ziehen
aber jetzt fangen wir erst einmal an und
ich zeige euch mal die zutaten die wir
dafür benötigen für das rezept braucht
er 900 kinder für zwei rote zwiebel oder
sechs schalotten 40 gramm stellte sich
bereits in wasser eingeweicht
ich habe ich 400 gramm ausland pilze 200
gramm champignons etwas sonnenblumenöl
oder ihr könnt auch olivenöl nehmen eine
zitrone einen esslöffel tomatenmark 600
gramm saure sahne oder schmand hier habe
ich ein paar gewürzgurken und drei
esslöffel senf und natürlich salz und
pfeffer zu fangen jetzt mit dem fleisch
an das wäre jetzt einfach in streifen
schneiden
jetzt sitze ich etwas öl in einem großen
topf und das sind top jetzt richtig heiß
werden
darin werde ich jetzt nämlich das
fleisch anbraten und das fleisch willig
der ist ganz heiß angebraten und dann
nehme ich es auch wieder heraus also ich
bereits einmal komplett rundherum angst
wieder heraus und dann bleibt eben auch
schön medium und schön
wenn die letzten zwei stöcken
angebrachten werden können wir aus
tomaten ins salz pfeffer geben
bei uns gibt es den van oder natur die
passen wirklich super wechsel auch bald
passieren machen dann kommt jetzt hier
das restliche öl mit rein und da werde
ich jetzt die zwiebeln darin anbraten
woran hat vergessen charlotten zu kommen
deswegen nehme ich jetzt hier roten aber
das ist nicht weiter schlimm
die zwiebeln werden jetzt einfach etwas
zwei bis drei minuten grafik angefragt
als nächstes gebe ich jetzt die piste
dazu
und normalerweise als dem ursprünglich
traditionellen rezepte werden gar keine
pilze verwendet aber es gibt einfach
schon ganz viele abwandlungen von daher
wenn ihr mögt dann geht's dir einfach
mit rein müssen auch keine ausnahmen
hilfe und steinpilze sein und alleine
reichen auch schon nehmt einfach das was
euch am besten schmeckt wir werden jetzt
hier mit angebraten und in der zeit kann
ich schon mal die steinpilze ausdrücken
und die flüssigkeit auffangen falls ich
noch welche benötigen
diese werden jetzt etwa zwei bis drei
minuten mit angebratenen bisher so ein
bisschen zusammenfallen jetzt kommt ja
noch das tomatenmark mit dazu jetzt kann
ich noch die saure sahne dazugeben und
ebenso die sauren gurken und auch
betonen war
jetzt könnt ihr gerne nach bedarf
einfach ein bisschen von der flüssigkeit
dazu geben
und falls ihr keine getrockneten pilze
verwendet habt könnt ihr einfach wasser
brühe oder auch weißwein dazu geben
hier kommt es noch der senf mit dazu und
dann werde ich die sauce mit salz und
pfeffer abschmecken und kurz aufkochen
lassen und im prinzip haben wir es jetzt
auch fast geschafft ich hole es gleich
noch ein bisschen schnittlauch wunder
terrasse das wird nämlich dann gleich
noch trüber gegeben und es fleisch
pflegen wir dann gleich nur noch rein
damit es warm wird die soße sitzt
perfekt abgeschmeckt jetzt kommt das
fleisch samt stimmt wieder zurück darin
einfach ein bisschen ziehen und jetzt
darf auch nicht mehr kochen denn
ansonsten wird sitzt zu werden die
nudeln habe ich jetzt auch schon
abgegossen da kommt jetzt einfach ein
stück butter mit dazu gibt natürlich
geschmack und die nudeln kleben nicht
und dann kann ich schon verlieren und
murat nach probieren
lieber morath du darfst jetzt
verbindlich gewesen schnittlauch drüber
da kann aber auch petersilie nehmen also
alles noch mal schon foto schießen
niedersachsen gleich im anschluss fotos
dann kann ich nichts doch gezogen
er schmeckt konnte schneidet die filets
anzieht das ist schön zart rosa yutong
das kamera kind das immer anschauen hier
genau das ist richtig toll aus was auch
gleich sagen sollte dass man das rezept
wenn das fleisch in der soße drinsteckt
haben uns dann wirklich sofort verwehrt
weil dann zehn jahre also dann zieht ist
fleisch noch ein bisschen und dann
bleibt eben schön medium als ihr könnt
jetzt nicht zubereiten und dann sage ich
mal eine stunde später essen dann ist
halt einfach durch das war schade also
gemacht aber so ganz das ist jetzt ihr
seht das ist immer noch leicht medium
ist es leicht medium leicht manchmal
sieht es zu kleine stößt sich aber so
muss ungefähr sein also bitte nicht zu
tode kochen backen braten ok darf ich
jetzt es ist ja also wir machen jetzt
butter nudeln dazu passt dass kartoffeln
passen super mögen würden auch gut passe
natürlich auch ein bisschen wandeln also
die erkenntnis und beim genau um und
schmeckt gut abgeschmeckt schon soll ich
mir das auch in kurzen geschäft in frage
macht uns ganz toll das freut mich ganz
ganz ganz tolles sonntags rezept meine
mama auf jeden fall
falls ihr auch eure eltern geschwister
freunde oder die familie begeistern
mainstädter und probiert das rezept
gerne mal auf schickt uns ein foto das
rezept gibt es nochmals nachlesen auf
sase mainz.de und ich wünsche euch einen
guten appetit uns allen natürlich auch
einen guten appetit wir werden jetzt
auch zusammen gleich essen und ja dann
bis zum nächsten mal
und wirklich super macht mir echt angst
all das freilich nur empfehlen
und da ist jetzt ganz wichtig dass sie
jetzt nicht komplett 900 gramm fleisch
darin anbraten
denn ansonsten